people of the internets hello and
welcome back to harry potter and the
chamber of secrets
for meeting for the first time i'm just
a dad who loves games and the stories
they tell ron relax for a minute buddy
just relax i'm trying to do the intro
here thank you ron
guys if you're here for the first time
we just
made our way into hogwarts so in the
last video we
rescued ron from the whomping willow and
literally we ended that episode with me
walking into hogwarts for the first time
so you can see here we're still
in the main entrance and my goodness ron
chill out dude chill out for just a
moment
okay all right so let's go and find ron
because he is
very anxious okay here we are dude where
are you gonna take us ron
okay all that and you're gonna walk this
slow
really you're gonna rush me so you can
walk this slow
[Music]
all right so this is exciting man this
is exciting to be in hogwarts for the
first time i wonder if he's gonna let me
like
is he gonna get mad if i try and look
around here because i bet
could we find some birdie bop beans on
these guys no no how about lumos
any hidden passageways ronnie you just
don't know what you're dealing with here
man
i like to explore i like to explore all
the areas so it looks like he's cool
with it
he's not going to get too mad first
floor transfiguration
got the fat fryer right there oh my
goodness and then we got the portraits
dude there's so many memories right now
second floor charms and library so it's
interesting how they
had to handle the layout or how i guess
how they chose to handle the layout for
this game young
potter how are you sir nicholas
well i would be nick if professor snape
hadn't caught me outside well
unfortunately although sometimes the
reason escapes me yes
you shouldn't be up this late you know
better get back to the gryffindor common
room before professor snape catches
let's go
let's get into the common room
see you later nick thanks for the tip
all right third floor defense against
the dark arts
and already seeing some of those
portraits repeat here
fourth floor is history of magic dude
this picture right here i remember this
one so much as a kid
because that guy
looks like so many of my baby pictures
right there
i kid you not i kid you not
it's almost like they stole a picture
from my i don't know maybe my mom sent
in a picture or something
no but i remember as a kid playing the
game and showing her this be like does
that not look like
i'm gonna have to show you guys sometime
seriously though look at that
look at that crazy dude all right fifth
floor we have non-magical studies wait
what
non-magical why don't they call it
muggle studies
sixth floor ancient runes
and then finally on the seventh floor we
have arithmancy and
gryffindor tower all right let's do this
ron
uh more ghosts floating around here i
gotta be honest guys i didn't know if i
was gonna be able to record this week
i had my second vaccine yesterday
and yesterday i was completely fine no
reaction at all i had it in the
afternoon
and then all night it was just like oh
my goodness i'm almost dead
i am almost dead
jeez we gotta find some uh
chocolate frogs get into the common room
harry she wants the password
of course i was the
look just tell us the new password
hermione
very well waddle bird yeah we wouldn't
have been allowed in
i do remember percy in the movie capet
draconis
capital all right waddle bird let's go
wattle bird why'd she close it on me
why'd she close it on me i don't get it
but yeah i didn't know if i was gonna be
able to record because i just i i had a
really rough night
chills and body aches you can trade all
kinds of things with them for spells yes
wow i must go put those beans to good
use
in this game through the reading room
there's a portrait on the other side
what's the password liberty gibbet
owen liberty he hates being disturbed
when he studied do they have chocolate
frogs that's what i need to know
i definitely need some help oh my
goodness there's the picture of me again
there it is it's following me now
yeah body aches though chills and then
woke up
this morning with a just a massive
headache massive headache and still
body ache so i'm recording this actually
pretty late at night it's almost 10 pm
my time and just now even feeling
up to being able to record wall sneak
what the heck is he gonna find me oh my
goodness
okay i think i just hey
[Music]
liberty
where did he go i thought i was done
he finally made it then i thought i was
done
mom's gonna kill ron when she finds out
i bet it was worth it to see snape's
face when you landed
sort of anyway welcome to not really yes
feel free to browse our extensive range
of wizard wheezes and magical
merchandise
everything priced at reasonable rates
and the only currency universally
accepted throughout hogwarts
30 bucks every flavor beans we're sure
there's something still crazy up dude
it cracks me up so much that that's the
currency
oh we got a wizard card right here we
only have 15 beans though that kind of
stinks
because we've been getting hit by
everything 20 30 bucks every flavor
beans oh man
if there's anything you'd like to how
much is his egg a stronger card
30 30 bucks everything 30. all right
hold on do you guys have any oh is this
a hold more
bean bag 20 30 bucks every favorite beer
dude i need oh my goodness there's so
many wizard cards in here
so many wizard cards okay can i run
around and whoops didn't mean to do that
are you serious i do the stink pellet
non-explodable luminous balloons are a
great way to destroy this is this a
spell right here i think it is
guys i i feel i am really ashamed
i'm really ashamed that i only have 15.
take a look around
how much is the alahomora spellbook 130
books every 100.
yeah we're definitely going to need the
alohomora spell book even though we
actually
learned it in year one
a little bit of a an immersion breaking
right there but hey
it's all good why are there not any
hidden beans anywhere dude
oh was that a hidden oh my goodness it
is
come on is there are there some beans
back here i really hope so
i got in here right here
man there's really not any beans in the
in the barrels in this game
all right let's crawl in where is this
leading
it's been so long since i played this
game like i really don't
[Music]
can i not crawl back in oh my goodness
it just put me back out here
okay fine
i didn't realize i was going back all
right we've got to find some more beans
check out the common room here oh my
goodness look at this
man so cozy so cozy to hear in the
gryffindor common room next to the fire
they really did a great job with that in
this game
like i know it's not exactly the way the
common room is
but ooh a potions kit bag lost potion
file case
last seen in the vicinity of the
herbology greenhouses if found
please return to this notice board now
see stuff like this
this is great man these little side
quests i
really like those little things like
that so we need to be on the lookout for
that potion skit bag
near the herbology greenhouse all right
ron what's up dude it's been a long day
really tired and i'm off to bed okay
yeah i need to get 20 birdie bot beans
for sure because
what i need to focus on first is getting
the uh
the bag so i can hold even more beans
let's see
if i go up here is it just going to make
us go to sleep or
am i free to go and explore the castle
oh
look at this man that looks like a
quidditch
picture of some sort i think
man this is awesome this
is awesome harry's bed right here next
to the window
where'd ron go where is he
i thought he was going up to bed
nobody's up here dude
all right i kind of want to end the day
but i want to make sure that there's
something i haven't
missed let me check my my little uh
the remember all here uh yep we've done
everything so we're ready to hit the end
of day there
all right good deal hopefully when you
wake up in the morning your health has
been
fully restored all right good morning
hogwarts in the daylight
wow this is glorious guys this is
glorious okay harry first one to bed
apparently last one to wake
all right let's head down the stairs
here see what we've got going for our
first day
morning ron do you know what class we've
got first i heard this flying
you heard right yes let's go
flying lesson to start the day love it
[Music]
i can't believe there's nobody bought
beans
anywhere in here let's see if the
the notice boards changed well still the
potions kit bag
i don't think it changes until you add
something
now is percy always gonna be in there i
wonder
oh here are all the students hey
slytherin what are you
dude why are you trying to get in there
oh now i do remember these get birdie
bop beans for
sure my health does not restore
after a full night's sleep are you
serious right now
i cannot believe that yeah let's talk to
this guy i want to see what he's what do
you think you're doing man trying to get
into the gryffindor
can i not talk to you stop it boom
take that secret entrance right here
dude this is going to be a problem man
it's going to be a problem for me to
stay on task in these videos
what the heck i can't even turn the
camera
[Music]
that's not fair dude i couldn't see him
does he crawl into oh wait open
dude where am i where am i
good thing is you guys i think love
exploring this area as much as i do
if this was fresh in my mind i'm sure
remember where all this leads but it's
been
so long since i played this game dude
so long okay he's back up so
yeah so far my biggest complaint with
this game is the camera
it's the camera like right now i can't
even like i'm trying to turn it around
there we go
finally let us okay that's locked that's
where i came in
that's locked as well
and then if i go here okay that leads
nowhere that's the door i went in
or is this the door i went in no that
one says locked
well well well
a spider webs on it we're gonna need to
burn that off later with incendio i
believe
i believe if i remember correctly
okay no it wouldn't still let you try it
even though it's locked
all right i'm gonna go on through this
door
and see where these stairs take us
yeah why is this camera not behind him
right now okay now it is
it's like why is it showing him running
toward the camera
there we go oh yes i for sure need those
because apparently sleeping at night
does not even restore your health to
full
all right we're almost back up to full
though thanks to the pumpkin
pumpkin pastries i guess we'll call them
no
now i'm not gonna be able to get those
beans back
that is so annoying we can't jump we
can't jump
up there to get them guys
okay let's push this
another secret passage oh we're just
back in here now
okay wait wait wait where is this
where is this we're on the fourth floor
history of magic now
all right getting really close to being
back at full health
okay that door is uh we could go in
there that one is locked
why are these students so quiet are they
afraid or something
they're like oh sorry didn't mean to do
that
oh and here's another secret passage
okay let's open this door oh this goes
into the classroom
okay it's not time for our class yet oh
and there's another chest this one
blocked by that
weird green slime
nothing going on in here right now
all right we should be able to use that
little secret passage over here though
see where that leads yeah right here
oh see oh my goodness dude like that is
just not even fair
that makes no sense and i i heard him i
heard him too late though
i'm gonna put that bean way up there i'm
just gonna like run through here
firing my wand hoping that it will hit
okay where does this lead oh my goodness
there's so many areas
come on nope all right this is good it's
gonna really
annoy me this is gonna really annoy me
guys that makes no sense
okay this chest is not protected by
anything so we can open that up and
we've got a wizard card let's go
[Music]
all right so that should increase our
health 43 cyprian yado
cypria and yalda only quidditch referee
ever to be
killed jeez during a match the
originator of the curse was never
caught but believed to have been a
member of the crowd
dang dude taking a guy out in the middle
of that many people but
hoping that you won't get
dude that is really annoying
like and then i can't even grab that
bean oh my goodness man
that's just not fair like you just you
can't see them
nothing no no no no
no no
wow i can't believe this
it's actually a challenge to keep the
beans in this game that's for sure
we got another chest right here okay
let's go another wizard card all right
okay so yeah we we should have increased
our health with the last lavia rashtrick
xavier xavier rashtrik flamboyant wizard
entertainer who vanished unexpectedly
while tap dancing
to a crowd of 300 in painswick and was
never seen again
all about the mysteries with these
wizard cards today right
that's crazy dude okay guys i am
already getting lost i am getting lost
we should probably just went on and met
ron but i am so
uh interested in exploring all this okay
another one
protected yeah we're gonna have to learn
some all the different spells to be able
to open this
yes here we go
dude as soon as i get to 20 i need to go
back and buy
dang this one had a lot all right we're
at 20 right now
yes two more pumpkin pastries
make it a third and that will max out
our health
what the heck that would just kept going
all right 26.
yeah these have a lot in them
they were all nasty
we go a nice cherry flavor
dude this was the room right here for
the beans
let's go i was gonna try it again see if
it was still
all right so they don't reset or
anything maybe if i exit the room and
then come back
all right well that was definitely worth
going in there let's keep heading down
here
all right go this way oh no that's the
way we came all right
go through here this is probably going
to bring us out into the main yeah
so i was thinking all right nice okay
so that's where i just came from
library annex dude i remember
absolutely loving exploring this area
here
it's it's giving me that weird sound
though like i'm trying to sneak around
so
apparently i'm not supposed to be here
library annex that goes into the main
library right there
where does this go oh look okay that
one's locked
how about you like why couldn't i go
into the main library
look we know about the restricted
section but okay what's this guy gonna
say to us
can i talk to you bro hello
he's just like did he just shake his
finger at me did he just say like no
don't go in here and apparently he
doesn't care that i'm here so i think
we're good
so you're gonna get mad about that
[Music]
you now have some luminous balloons you
could equip them
uh to b y or x from the inventory in
your membrane as you would have spelled
release a balloon press the appropriate
button use a luminous balloon as a
distraction
prefix will always run to investigate
okay good to know
is that more of them right here
nothing in that one
ooh birdie about bean birdy bop bean
for some reason i'm thinking that you
can't go to fred and george's
during the day i mean they have those
guys have to go to class
sometime right right
that i could be remembering wrong but
i'm about to go test it out
oh my goodness that's right some of
these areas are locked
eventually we're going to be able to get
behind there
dude this they really did a lot of smart
things with this game
they really did the loading screens are
kind of a pain
watch watching it back you guys don't
have to worry about the loading screens
though because i skipped through them
but like just to come into the library
here and then when i came into the annex
of the library
loading screens both times
all right another luminous balloon and
we are almost
it wasn't looking good on our bodybot
beans for a while there
but now we've gotten 40 and are getting
really close to maxing out so i think
what we're gonna do
is i'm gonna head out of the library
here after i finish breaking all these
jars
i'm gonna head out of the library and i
know there's a lot more to explore here
that we just
oh wait hold on we'll go ahead and check
the stream
i think i'm still holding that wigan
weld potion
filled with stamina is that one already
i think that one's already full though
yeah
it's already full oh i keep hitting the
wrong button to get in the menu
yeah that one that one's already good
because it's not giving me the option
so all right so yeah i think what we're
gonna do
is i'm gonna leave the library after i
break all these i'm gonna try to go back
up
to the gryffindor common room and see if
i can visit fred and george because i
want to buy that
expansion for the birdie bop bean bag if
i can't get that
or even if i can then we're going to go
and head down to ron and see if we can
get to the first flying lesson
like see this area right here we had to
go through a loading screen just to get
in here
i don't know why it's making that weird
sound like i know you you sneak through
this area
in a later part of the game but why
right now
all right back into the main area here
so let's go here
and then let's go wow we're all the way
down on the second floor
hello nick again what's the matter
uh a matter of no importance it's just
that some properly decapitated pot more
won't let me join the
headless hunt apparently they only
accept huntsman whose heads have
completely parted company with their
bodies the death day party
not to worry young potter as i said
such a strange scene so many interesting
moments at that death day party
all right so apparently nick's just like
dropping some info on me there
okay let's head on up here
back all the way up to the top okay now
let's see
if it will let me go in to visit fred
and george
maybe even when they're not there i can
access their shop
yes it does reset oh but it only gave me
one that time
okay here we go let's see
[Music]
okay yeah i don't have to sneak around
right now
oh look oh it's locked
so yeah i thought for some reason i i
was thinking that you could only go in
there at night
so now i'm gonna have to make sure that
i
don't lose these birdy bop beans
throughout the day right
you know we're going to you know we're
gonna get hit way too many times
[Music]
okay now we're gonna go all the way down
and meet ron
i'm gonna try not to get distracted this
time guys
i should probably go ahead and save
though right
okay save complete let's head all the
way back down now
yeah man like so far my only complaints
with this game
are the camera and the load screens
everything else even now all these years
later like i feel like it holds up
pretty well
wait is that supposed to be ravenclaw
and the purple
i'm confused no ravenclaw's in the blue
right there that's gryffindor
you're hufflepuff and purple
say what
wait a second i do not remember this why
did they have hufflepuff as purple and
not yellow
why or is my game just glitching out on
me
right now all right ron let's go to the
flying lesson harry
let's go outside oh the remin ball's
flashing though okay that's it
that's it that's all it wants me to do
oh is that neville that looks like
neville
can i talk to you dude yes we can
what neville's game menu i do
not remember this gnome dunking
throw some gnomes in the lake and gnome
tossing
try to beat the gnome tossing record
yeah we're gonna have to
schedule that for another day but i
definitely want to try that out at some
point okay what's over here
okay i was afraid it was about to start
a loading screen is this where we go to
practice
flying oh no nope apparently not
okay
[Music]
so you couldn't like fully explore the
grounds
it's so interesting that there's like no
loading at all for that and then for a
lot of the stuff inside the castle
they need to load why can't i not just
like
okay let me just like barely go okay to
fly and practice there we go
i guess right i guess right that time
yeah see like no loading for that to fly
last year he apparently is directed at
you mr longbottom
this is the longest of course is in
order okay see
they at least try to make it connect in
this game
[Music]
fly up and hover a few feet from the
ground okay
up harry's still holding his wand i'm
not sure why
yeah let's go
okay up what am i supposed to do
now fly back down to the ground and
hover above it
okay yes ma'am
your broom has now been configured if
you want to alter the configuration at
any time
you can do this from the options menu
okay
you seem to have lost oh so i can refer
the ability let's move on to something a
little more difficult
you see before you a course comprised of
enchanted rings
what you must do is to fly through as
many of these rings as possible in the
correct order
you ready potter begin a to accelerate
oh my goodness this is gonna be so much
easier
so much easier than in sorcerer's stone
when i was trying to control it with
just a
couple of keys on the keyboard look at
this
chat look at this pinpoint control
right tin ring examination
like it's nothing well you complete the
course
oh okay as many rings as you can in a
set time in a set time created several
now
[Music]
yeah we need a little challenge
[Music]
oh my goodness dude i this this is like
so many memory flashbacks right now
i spent so much time just flying around
hogwarts
oh no that one moved on me that one
moved on me she got me
oh gosh okay not
terrible we recovered nicely there
it's looking a little shaky for a while
okay that counted somehow that one did
not that one did not
ah we botched that oh we botched all
three of those
[Music]
well done
[Music]
one lesson ron's like dude i gotta i
gotta go to bed man
now see is this like the american
grading system a
or is this like the owl grading system a
for acceptable
oh a plus okay so i think this is like
the american style grading system
report card 70 house points it was
and then we just got an a there so yeah
we could we could do a lot better than
that
oh everybody left all right i think we
should try again oh mr
potter let's go i think we should try
again let's see if we can get that to an
a plus
like i i can't decide if i like the
controls how they are
let's get started or if i want to invert
them
yeah except right now for the
examination
where a grade will be awarded depending
on how well you complete oh yes
same same thing you must fly through as
many rings as you can and you don't have
to tell me again
i've created several new enchantments
for the rings
this is one of those like small another
quality of life things that
would have made the game maybe a little
bit better right like she doesn't need
to tell me the whole thing again
like see right there it feels nice but
because right now i'm going non-inverted
oh like see right there
[Music]
i went the wrong way
i mean we've missed a lot of those green
ones at the end though
we just improve on that
oh see right there dude
what was i last time 30 i believe
okay we already beat last time
truly excellent a plus
let's go dude come back and see me here
at any time of the day
i may have to try it again later on and
and reverse it see if that feels a
little better
yeah so 35 rings get you an a plus i
think we had 30 or something 32 the
first time and it was just an a
all right let's go dude i do not even
know which way to go so many different
areas here
go back this way yep to the hogwarts
main entrance
harry's out of breath too what's up
neville
go racing around hogwarts with the other
students
we gotta do this we gotta do this
oh is it you wait to race you harry yes
let's go
five beans to race you i don't know
about that but fine
uh how come she got a head start
[Music]
dude can i not go any faster
harry why are you so slow dude catch up
hopefully the rings like build speed
yeah we're gaining we're gaining
dude this is so awesome this is so
awesome
the music too man
yeah we definitely slowed down missing
those rings right there
i think we missed two
i wish i had like a rear view mirror i
want to look i want to see how close
she is to me oh she doesn't just zoom by
right at the end
okay the green one i bet the green one's
the end
yes oh she was right there
she was right there and you get a famous
wizard card for it
yes dude
cess isn't it cersei or am i just
thinking game of thrones
lived on an island of a
expert at turning lost sailors into pigs
wow very nice very nice
okay so do we race again no i don't want
to race again
how do i get back to school how do i how
do i get back
no i don't want to race i want to just
like
i want to get back to school like how
where do i
wait do i just have to end the day
no there's got to be a way
what am i doing wrong guys there's got
to be a way to wait maybe i have to talk
to her and say no
let's race harry i won't lose this time
it will cost
10 beans and then i'm gonna say decline
there we go okay yeah another weird like
it shouldn't be like that you should be
able to just walk away somehow
dude neville with the mini games though
love it
okay now back in the castle uh i guess
we're done for the day let's check the
remember all one more time now that
we're inside
yeah that's it so i i wonder if there's
a way i'm gonna i think i'm gonna go
ahead and hit
end day right now and what i'm hoping
is that it'll just take me to the
evening hours
and then i can go into fred and george's
shop
and upgrade those
oh here we go the end of day tally
gryffindor we did get an a
plus we did get an a plus in our flying
lesson
okay 80.
hufflepuff at a 65 not bad not bad
ravenclaw ravenclaw with 76 very close
what's slytherin gonna be at
slytherin with another also a 76 so
close so far 80 gryffindor 76 ravenclaw
76 slytherin and then 65 for hufflepuff
okay perfect we are back in the
gryffindor common room it is the evening
hours
so now i'm going to go back down and see
if i can sneak in there with percy
harry just the person i've been looking
for
something no he's going to throw in
there
and i suppose you want me to get him out
would you
that's it harry already knows what's up
why can't you do it hermione you already
know the spell
anyway wait he's out where
this way okay yeah can i go can i just
please go in there first he was looking
for trevor his toad
and he went the wrong way now he's stuck
or neville
well can't you get him out hermione no
exactly
we need a severing charm which you
totally know
i'm one of those at this time of night a
bulgy green house three in the ground
oh my goodness she's wanting me to sleep
now you're going to have to find out how
to pull up pork clumps
if you go to the library there's an
excellent book by professor lockhart
that'll tell you how to do it okay so
i've got to go into the library multiple
steps to get a copy of lockhart's book
and then go out into the grounds and
find my way into the pathology
greenhouse to get the severing charm
yes what did he say
hurry up he can't breathe
yeah there's no way hermione would not
know the severing sharp
all right but first i need to go in here
i need to go in here
even though percy just like patrolling
all night
oh see like the camera right now it's so
strange
it's like i'm controlling a little uh
like patrol camera or something in the
top corner
there we go liberty jibber flibbety
jibbet let me in
okay how many did we end with i think
like 45 or something
so we're definitely gonna buy the the
one to increase
what is this right here that's like an
extra wig and weld potion i believe
that's gonna cut us in half right there
i'd like to buy that please
you can now but now exactly now we can
hold up to 100.
feel free
how much is it 30 30 bucks every flavor
beans
oh 30 we don't have enough darn it
are all the wizard cards thirty
okay all right and then how much was
that one was 100 i believe for the spell
right there
okay let's go back out can i go the way
i came
or anything here through that hidden
spot
yeah you can just go right back through
here remember the last time i went
through
the other way
[Music]
yeah i'm just gonna run right by you
percy
i'm just gonna run right by you
apparently you you can't hear my
footsteps which is good it's a good
thing
all right so now let's go out here
all right so really i just want to find
a save point
i think it would be yeah there's one
right there okay yeah i think that's
going to be a good spot to end
so next time when we pick up we will
have this right here so that that's a
pretty lengthy quest i'm guessing
thank you all so much for watching if
you enjoyed this video don't forget to
give it a thumbs up
if you're new here also hit that
subscribe button and don't forget to
ring the bell so you won't miss any of
our new videos
guys thank you all so much for watching
i'll talk to you again soon